welcome back to new rockstars it's a big
question okay on to some uh
bite size questions that philip is going
to answer for us uh we actually got some
real mail this time
all right this one was mailed into us
from uh jackson stewart
uh and it was awesome he's a uh he's a
marine at camp pendleton
and he watches with his one and a half
year old son jackson and he sent us this
awesome letter sweet the picture of his
son they watch their videos together
they're
so nice to send us uh his question i
hope they didn't watch that one episode
or a couple of these episodes recently
well it wouldn't have i don't know if
he's learning
everything about palpatine's sexual
history
he asks what do you guys think became of
cap's broken shield which you just
brought up
you think he kept it maybe he gave it to
morgan after all so that she could sled
yeah so the actress i think did use it
for sweating actually i don't know if we
have that but
i so i i went painstakingly frame by
frame and re-watched endgame oh no how
sad my job is
uh no it's fun i got to uh watch again
and i tracked it the whole way
i really tried to keep track of it the
best i could uh
and it absolutely disappears at a
certain point there's a moment
cap has that shield all the way very
close to the near end of the movie
but there's specifically a moment where
thanos
is trying to beat captain marvel to the
quantum uh like device that's in the
back of scott lang's van
and thanos throws his maybe adamantium
sword
into the van and there's this huge shock
wave that goes off
and we see a bunch of characters just
get blown away
we don't clearly see who gets blown away
in that moment
but ever since that happened after that
we never see cap with the shield again
so likely that he just gets separated
from his shield at that moment
uh and then i i feel like it might be
stretching a little bit
but then you see captain marvel and
thanos fight and there's uh well it was
highlighted in the frame here
i think it could be part of the debris
that you see back through you kind of
see a little bit of a star
maybe some circles around it so it's
probably in that debris field somewhere
um interesting but do i think somebody
salvaged it and sold it on
marvel ebay yes absolutely is it
possible that when that quantum tunnel
exploded
the shield fragment got sucked back in
time
yes that's what happened and it
immediately decapitated tony stark's
parents
and they died a whole different way all
right
and thank you jackson and nathan stuart
for watching our videos you guys are
very nice to males in
solid bold uh who asks which metal is
stronger adamantium or vibranium and why
if they both exist in marvel why isn't
wolverine
why wasn't wolverine made using
vibranium and you have one minute to
answer it okay and they're they're like
we should have made them out of
vibranium yeah no uh it's a it's an
interesting question so adamantium
and vibranium are both considered to be
crazy strong right
uh but if i can simplify it as much as i
can adamantium
is a metal that it's special property is
that it
is so incredibly hard that's what she
said does not
bend and that's the unique feature about
it vibranium
is actually shouldn't be compared in
terms of strength it does a different
thing entirely vibranium is almost more
similar to rubber
yeah it's super you can make weaves out
of it in a minute yeah
yeah uh so the fact that it vibrates
what it does is it's actually
incredibly able to bend and quickly
retake its own form
so in the comics adamantium can actually
pierce vibranium
uh wolverine has been able to stab
through black panther's costume
but vibranium is actually able to take
more of a hit
and kind of keep on ticking like the
energizer brother bunny right you have
to beat him up and then he
keeps going he just give me another move
killed a lot of gangs uh he always gets
back up um
but the the one thing that uh people
might have seen in the mcu
is it's possible that thanos is sword
maybe
was made from adamantium because it's
able to destroy cap's shield
which is made from vibranium but it's
hardest i would say technically if you
mean which one's harder
it's adamantium but which one is like a
better
suit to make out of adamantium suit kind
of sucks actually it's like a clunky
yeah exactly
medieval so they're not the same kind of
thing but adamantium can pierce soybeans
interesting choice it's like your
adamantium claws pierced this vibranium
shirt that one episode
uh oh yeah there were pencils but yeah
but before we continue thank you to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has
zero calories kid it tastes great
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from this one
is sour heads which i gotta say isn't
too sour it's more like the nice sweet
aftertaste of like a sour candy
we get like the essence of sour but not
offensive
and you're so unoffended you wake up and
you charge through the rest of the day
like you're punching through metropolis
skyscrapers check out bang on instagram
you can get 25 off with your order at
bangenergy.com when you use the code
newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best bang self thanks again
to bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
another piece of mail we got was from
the burrito family
uh we have a big question who lost their
arm in star wars the rise of skywalker
so this question is about this theory of
in every movie somebody
loses an arm no matter what movie it is
a bug's life
yeah it's gone uh no in star wars movies
people are known for losing limbs right
i do have a list of it it's extremely
common to lose more than just an arm
if you go to episode one darth maul
loses both legs that's right
episode two zam wessel oh that was the
assassin
yes her right arm the acklay loses its
legs
and anakin actually now i wanted to lose
this that's right yeah count dooku
episode three uh count dooku loses both
hands
uh general grievous loses two hands but
he's still fine mace windu loses his
right hand
poor anakin loses his left arm and both
his legs uh and then a new hope that's a
famous
one where panda baba uh loses his right
arm that's right
empire strikes back a wampa loses its
right arm c3p loses all of his limbs he
just can't find him
uh and then that's when we're famously
luke loses his right hand
and then in return of the jedi vader
loses his uh right hand
but that's actually like the only ones
that are established as definite
arm losses if you go to the new trilogy
they actually
haven't shown limbs uh being cut off
they show burns there's things like uh
in deleted scenes maybe someone lost one
yeah or something we didn't see
like uh c-3po again clearly there's been
an arm replacement because you have the
right
arm right you probably don't recognize
me because of the red arm
it wasn't a requirement of the new
trilogy that they lose limbs but the one
thing i'll point out is my favorite
thing to acknowledge actually about some
of the cool stuff that
that happens in rise of skywalker uh if
nobody lost their arm as far as we can
tell they are on mustafar which is where
anakin lost a lot of limbs so there's
limbs floating around sure
but uh while no one loses one it
is the only moment where someone gains
one
because palpatine when he finally is
taking from the jedi
gains an arm and starts to regrow one he
sucks energy out of the dyad and the
force
it wasn't totally exactly but it does
feel it does feel very purposeful that
they were trying to say like he's doing
a reverse jedi movement
whatever right you know yeah closing
that book again it's like poetry so if
they rhyme
okay well great answer there thank you
for all that research and thank you for
these questions
guys uh remember you can you can tweet
us at new rockstars with the hashtag
bigquestion
and send a mail at rpo box so we can
feature your letters and hopefully
they'll get out of the splash zone next
time why is there hair
here i'm sorry um
i'm just uh real quick remembering that
the there was a lot of homoerotic energy
to start this episode
and kind of a lot to end it it's a real
book and a dick and did it uh
yeah in a wet t-shirt um i didn't intend
for it to go that crazy uh and uh
subscribe to new rockstars
um here on youtube and subscribe if
you're listening to the podcast version
wherever you get your podcast
and uh you can follow us at philip
molina at eavos
and we'll see you next week guys
[Music]
you